what must be an interesting emotional
rollercoaster ride for you because as a
filmmaker we want to make an audience
feel and hear you have but they've
turned against you and it looks like
even
in terms of some of the YouTube comments
people weren't sure if it was real or
not
and so how have you handled that lately
with this lady
what we actually even the slate escape
we showed it south by southwest we had
three screenings there the first two
screens we didn't say anything
beforehand that it wasn't real just to
see how people would react and they
there was outrage and there were people
walking out but it was still healthy you
have people whereas in Kosovo that
screening just wasn't healthy it was
just a level of destruction there there
wasn't wasn't inspiring conversation
anymore because it ended with with the
festival organizers are coming up to me
and saying whatever you do don't leave
the theater there is a mob gathering
outside to deal with that's a mob and
Kosovo you know that's what kind of melt
that gets you killed it's not a mob in
front of the chinese theater or
something so I really crossed the line
there and then in the third screening at
South by Southwest before it actually
said this is not real the actors are
right here and they're going to be up
here for Q&A afterwards it's all
scripted you know
and it didn't matter you know the
audience was as impacted as they were
when we didn't say Morgan we didn't say
and that to me was really satisfying
because then now I kind of played fair I
put the cards on the table and said this
is what this is and that they still
follow that journey and went more as
emotional as they were when they thought
it was a little
that was a really satisfying experience
so since then we've always said it and
there's a letter and the DVD to the two
of you are saying this is actually not a
documentary everyone is still naive who
participate with they're all actors how
and we'll see how that actually a lot of
comments that we get actually say I wish
I had known that this is not real for
people that really liked the film they
know it's kind of the other way when you
can't win this thing you know if you
don't say it it's like what are you
doing why are you tricking us and if you
are saying it then it's like our would
have been an even stronger experience so
what's happening now is that people that
see it and know that it's fake show to
their friends and they take out the
letter so the friends smell think it's
real but at least that's not my
responsibility and what you know I've
done whatever I could to kind of make
that clear
pull a prank like that on their friends
you